simply leaned over 20 she sort of
lowered her voice and she said you know
race it's a problem and from that moment
we began to bring it back out of the
realm of whispers to think about how
each of us in our disciplines are
affected by the other um that that the
use of algorithms in certain legal
outcomes in things like bail hearings in
carcere ality but also in insurance and
in finance and everything else is
certainly directing and undermining some
of the precepts of due process
you
the more I read and the more I read
about race and the pervasiveness of
racism and how it permeates absolutely
everything the more I realized I knew
nothing and also realized that we have
to have a better understanding of
literally the roots of how all of this
racism is entering the data because in
machine learning you train algorithms
based on historical data and if you you
can try to learn and then adjust but if
you want to learn from something that's
reasonable you have to understand where
is all of that stuff and that's what Pat
and I were talking about and we talked
about different fields different
subfields in medicine in genomics in
housing and so on and Pat has is
phenomenal intellect and breadth and you
seemed to know experts in all of these
areas oh I had a wish list and also it
is because I've been teaching
collaboratively in mostly in the area of
genomics and and DNA I was teaching with
Robert Pollock who's a by a geneticist
and biologist at Columbia by co-teaching
with him a course called human identity
DNA and the Scientific Revolution and it
was I think a small leap to think about
how race as its embedded in our society
is predictive of our particular outcomes
and that prediction architecture is
really a reduction to begin with but
then the question of how algorithms are
further reductive and push those
reductions out into society at large it
was a very similar problem to the way in
which for example population genetics is
taking a particular history
particularly history of percentages
Oktar owns half-breeds that sort of
thing and then putting it out back up it
was rien scribing these structures of
segregation of divisions that I think
whose habits of thinking are endemic in
not just race but society generally but
but but the fact of the contest between
precedent as a legal structure and
prediction as a model that you're
dealing with from a very different
perspective clash come together and
affect what we think of as
discrimination then on the computer
science side there are several people
who have been looking at these questions
and my hope was to bring in a few
representative samples or a few best but
just sort of sprinkled them throughout
and try to open a dialogue between the
computer science community that the
theoretical computer science community
and the much broader community that had
all of these kinds of expertise that we
really need so two of the highlights for
me were Dorothy Roberts I think saying
and don't treat race as the variable
treat racism as the variable that was
actually good because I think that comes
up over and over again as a stumbling
block but I think you know a corollary
of what that is was is is that race is
to some degree or to it race let me not
qualify that race is incoherent as a
category and racism derives its power
precisely from that incoherence and that
it moves its moba it's it's not the same
thing all the time and it means
and the ghost hosts keep changing and
the degree to which it becomes treated
as though it's a static thing blinds us
to its ubiquity and to its again the
underlying power of it being
shape-shifting interestingly I've been
in contact a lot with the Census Bureau
lately because of their forthcoming
deployment of differential privacy and I
noticed that a surprising fraction of
the decennial census has to do with race
and ethnicity and I was very curious for
technical reasons whether race that
people report for themselves changes or
not does it stay fixed or do people vary
it and according to the Bureau
it varies wildly so there's a and it's a
safest way to look up the the incredible
variation in not just what the census
takes but how people's self identify us
is - there's there's a so called data
artist named Josh Begley and he does
things if you look it up Josh Phegley
race box he takes the census from its
origins in the 1700s all the way to the
and and you can go through and see all
of the different categories and racial
categories but but it's you know just in
our time people suddenly have started
using the word biracial as though
there's is that here buy anything or I
mean they sort of implied purity of
these categories but in fact
simultaneously these categories have
social meaning they have social
consequence and they do they're linked
to two particular social outcomes so
it's important to be able to find some
vocabulary to describe it but also to
continuously interrogate what this means
and it varies with politics with moment
with migration
you know with things like the Chinese
Exclusion Act who's Asian who's South
Asian whether or not the largest
demographic in the United States is
sentence of slaves within the United
States or whether or not it is people
from the Caribbean or from Brazil or
from sub-saharan West Africa those sorts
of things
inflict the kinds of obstacles and the
kinds of again social I'm talking about
so I think another couple of things that
really struck me was the articulation of
the desire to abolish population
genetics as a field as a research
discipline and all that that entails and
the discussion of how they I forget the
name the medical data they you know know
the something very close to that how the
articles are imbued with these racial
categories that have been dressed up as
if their biology or and it doesn't make
any medical sense and so so much of that
is suspect and yet and it doesn't make
any human sense right this is Gammons
right pointing out that the
categorizations that have been carried
forward to this day go all the way back
to louisiana seeds [ __ ] they're
still we're still using words like
[ __ ] and Caucasoid and yeah right
and so if this is what you're starting
with what are you going to come up with
this is the classic garbage in garbage
out and so so this was all very
interesting and there's been a lot of
talk of writing a manifesto and starting
a movement to to to mobilize around the
ethical use of data and algorithms but
from this very informed and disciplinary
perspectives manifesto says it should be
on a flag but just as summarize some of
the concerns that we've come away from
in this meeting so I think what we do
hope to come up with some sorts of
documents and resources yeah
algorithms are being used in ways that
foreclose the sort of human judgment
with which the responsibilities of
courts and sort of liberty interests are
ordinarily patrolled and so the use of
algorithms in say the granting of fail
or the granting of role based on the
likelihood of recidivism is to some
degree in some jurisdictions being
governed by algorithms that are
proprietary so one really doesn't know
what the metrics are of that but some
reports suspect that it must be things
like zip code which is not about what
you have done it's not about your
individual likelihood of going out and
repeating but in its association and as
a matter of due process the larger
Association where you live becomes a
kind of algorithmic redlining that it
says that you're from an area a
dangerous area whose population has a
higher risk and therefore that that
probability is assigned to you as an
individual and it becomes disabling it
becomes hobbling in terms of your life
chances if you don't even know that
that's what you have to respond to where
you went to school what high school you
went to what the gang rate is at that
school and then there's an aside from
what may be built into these algorithms
there's the problem of the fact
they are back right Harry they act like
witnesses our Constitution says you have
the right to confront and cross-examine
those witnesses but if their proprietary
algorithms there is no chance to
excavate them and figure out what the
you know what it is that who or what
this witness is against you and in
addition to that the the the way in
which algorithms being deferred to
disables the actual social workers or
the opinions of bail officials in jails
or wardens for example who might be
making a different disposition based on
the fact that they know you intimately
and instead the deference you know the
deference goes to these these
agglomerations of metrics that are
beyond you that are abstractions of of
your their stochastic models of who you
ought to be or who you might be who you
will be but they're not about who you
are yeah so someplace so so while
simultaneously agreeing with everything
that pat has said she's also touched on
some really interesting technical points
for example talking about the
proprietary nature of the algorithms
it's not clear that if the algorithm
were not proprietary it would be any
better if the algorithm were public and
available for inspection it's not clear
that anybody can understand what an
algorithm does and that one of the
speakers at the workshop was Zachary
Lipton who wrote a wonderful very broad
audience friendly article called the
mythos of model interpretability
and it it's sort of very thoughtfully
lays out what could you possibly mean
when you say you want to understand what
the algorithm does here's one meaning
you here are some problems with that
here's another possibility and here are
problems with that and it's not intended
to be a final world word but it's it's
very it's very compelling in terms of
how difficult it
to understand what an algorithm is doing
another and I was gonna say man I'm not
I'm not saying that they're on a myriad
number of flaws but right basic things
like saying who you associate with yes
um not even associate with but where you
live right or who's lived in your
building as a way of judging you it's
sort of it's it's it's like McCarthyism
you know it's like who you're hanging
out with rather than a judgement of and
so that those kinds of metrics are very
clearly illegal if they were you if they
if you could disaggregate them from them
from from the algorithm and that's all
there's some things that are very clear
I said I was agreeing with you but I was
also highlighting some issues that's
like you if the some if the algorithm
allowed you to figure out that that is
what it was doing then you would you
would say oh this is disallowed but it's
there's no guarantee even when you see
the algorithm that its form would allow
you to understand that and if it had
been trained on data that that had that
message in it in some form then what
what is produced the classifier that's
produced or the scoring function that's
produced doesn't necessarily label and
say oh this is why we are included in
we're giving this one okay so that was
one technical point another technical
point was you know Pat mentioned how the
algorithms to provide predictions they
give you a probability that somebody is
going to I don't know commit another
offense or whatever it is and then the
question is what if that probability
mean so let's think about what's to make
it more neutral let's look at a tumor
and say what is the probability that
this tumor is going to metastasize if
you follow the following course of
treatment well you can't sort of run
this experiment over and over again with
the same tumor and say okay in 30% of
the chance of trials it metastasized so
you have to assign and meet a meaning to
a probability for this individual and
that's some
that nobody understands I think really
mathematically unless maybe the Bayesian
have a view of it but so so I think this
is one of this is maybe the central
problem of a big portion of AI right now
is to understand the meaning of a
prediction score okay it's not just that
the algorithms are a pig is also that
they are designed with efficiencies in
mind and efficiencies are reductive so
the combination of reductive miss
efficiencies as you say at the
structural level which often come with
economic efficiencies cost-benefit
analyses that have you know that sort of
reproduce themselves and things like the
Boeing catastrophe or the Flint water
you know we're going to save money and
but but nevertheless efficiency is held
out as a value that I think mutes the
human cost of using an algorithm for say
for example in the context of child
removal in some counties in the United
States there has been great conversation
about using these because they're
efficient they're supposedly better
easier and I think it in many people's
mind less assailable they have more
authority than the variability of judges
or social workers judgment but I think
the deference is frequently rooted in
discussions of efficiency we don't have
enough people to do this anyway and this
is as good as it gets and it takes these
broad assessments of very broad
populations with no I mean it's it's I
would phrase it a little bit differently
it was very little accountability for
the incredible complexity of a family
unit or not a unit sounds too bounded I
mean really is before the family context
of a larger dynamics of family so I
really have a lot of questions around
this and there's just so much I don't
know but this debate about clinical
versus actuarial methods is
very old in penology it dates back at
least to 28 1928 with birches saying you
know prediction is feasible about how
criminals would do coming and then in
psychology dates back to Paul Neal 1954
and the the as I understand it and I may
be wrong but the evidence seems to be
that actuarial techniques are more
accurate than individual clinical
judgments and I don't know what to make
of that because it it it flies in the
face of the idea of the the image of the
really experienced and wise judge
clinician with whatever making a
prediction or or determining whether
somebody is or is not a danger and and
just these sort of cold hard numbers and
I I mean I just have a bunch of
questions but the literature then the
things that I've been reading lately
seem to say that the statistical methods
are more accurate as a group but not
necessarily of course for individuals
yeah and maybe at the collective level
for certain in certain contexts but
there's also but one if it's done
absolutely well then this is a way of
you know if it's so depends upon what
information goes into the algorithm
absolutely and whether or not it is
actually reporting what it's supposed to
be reporting as opposed to being used
many decisions right that effect in ways
for which the data isn't applicable
because it's not a group you're dealing
in a and the child welfare an example
that you're alluding to from Allegheny
County is a great example because it's
it's using whether the child will be
removed from the home in the next two
years and whether
there will be a call about the same
family or child in the next two years it
is using those as proxies for whether
the child is actually going to be abused
or neglected and you know just think
geographically if you're in some really
remote area what's the chance that
someone's going to call a complaining
about your treatment of your child
versus whether you're in a densely
packed neighborhood where people are
observing you all the time so it's just
a wonderful example about how these
efficiencies that you were talking about
in the proxies or just and what it is
that we're calling accurate because it's
exactly back exactly know then it's you
know that accuracy doesn't write
anything other than we this is the pro
quickness and so on the one hand 23andme
says it's not going to use race as a
category it doesn't want to reinstate
but on the other hand it couples with
the world flip over FIFA and to identify
yourself as you know if you you know if
you have X percentage I mean just a very
language of percentages that come from
Ireland
therefore you should read for Ireland so
they're reinstating a kind of positivism
of identity that is rooted in genes that
is rooted in blood they're using the
vocabulary with which we all grew up
which is that these identities predict
outcomes and even as they're denying it
they re inscribing it I think that's why
the whole premise of breaking us into
these into these categories is a new
form of speciation and it's a new form
of surgery and it's a new form of what
sometime identify is racism but I think
if race is viewed as a category mistake
we are Rhian scribing old vocabulary
filling them with new meaning that is
actually biologists which was the dream
which was Hitler's dream now now these
categories really are going to have
biological meaning which will carry all
the social baggage of previous
generations
you